my name is Kelly ke Li McAllister
embassy capital AL IST ER and I'm the
TBI spokesperson or public information
officer so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna read our prepared statement first
and then I'll be glad to take any
questions that you may have just know
that we were on the very onset of this
investigation so I'm going to be quite
limited in what I'm able to say okay
everybody ready at the request of 30th
District Attorney General Amy Weirich
TBI agents are investigating the
circumstances surrounding an
officer-involved shooting that occurred
in the Frazer community of Memphis
Wednesday evening preliminary
information indicates that at
approximately 7:00 p.m. multiple
officers with the United States Marshal
Service Gulf Coast Regional Fugitive
Task Force encountered a male wanted on
multiple warrants outside of a home in
the 2700 block of Durham Street as he
was getting into a vehicle while
attempting to stop the individual he
reportedly rammed his vehicle into the
officers vehicles multiple times before
exiting with a weapon the officers fired
striking and killing the individual no
officers were injured this remains an
active and ongoing investigation as TBI
special agents and forensic scientists
continue to work to gather any and all
relevant interviews and evidence as in
any case TBI investigation investigative
findings will be shared with the
District Attorney General throughout the
process for her review as is our policy
the TBI does not identify the officers
involved in these types of incidents and
instead refers those questions back to
the respective department any updates on
this investigation can be found on our
website
TBI newsroom comm what um were the
warrants that this man was
at this point what I can say if he was
wanted on felony warrants and it was US
Marshals involved in the police action
shooting no Shelby County sheriff's
deputies or Memphis police officers said
is correct
u.s. marshals were involved in this one
there with the Gulf Coast fugitive
regional task force and I don't believe
I said that correctly but it's the u.s.
marshals and it will be in the statement
that I will put on our website but it's
the Gulf Coast Regional Fugitive Task
Force and they work I believe in kind of
the Southeast region can you confirm the
identity I cannot at this time was the
weapon found that he reportedly
displayed after it's part of our
investigation can you comment on the
events that happened following this
police actions shooting in the community
in the Frazer humanity the TVI is
responsible solely for the
officer-involved shooting that
investigation anything beyond that I
would have to refer you to Memphis
police
like that they get called up in India
one of the delays and getting
information to you was making sure that
that seemed less secure for our agents
as well as our forensic scientists did
the branding of the cars if that was he
reportedly trying to get away or we
could only assume so I really can't
comment on that
pardon again that's something I would
have to refer you back to Memphis police
on if you think of something feel free
to interrupt but this in the statement
that I read will be on our website at TV
I'm newsroom calm if you guys want to
review that and if you have any further
questions you can always email them to
TVI dot media at TN gov was it one
marshal that would had that you know
inspiring or the multiple officers have
to fire that is part of our
investigation but we do know that
multiple we do know that multiple
marshals were on the scene
you know that's something that will be
part of our investigation but something
I really can't speak to those kind of
specifics now no other injuries poor
people bear at the home when it's this
happened I'm not sure if other
individuals were at the home again that
would be part of our investigation
because they could potentially be
witnesses where any of the marshals
injured no no officers were injured a
lot the whole night and not to my
knowledge it was in front of the a home
on Durham correct and all this happened
outside the home you said he was spotted
in a vehicle outside the home I believe
he was spotted as he was exiting the
home and getting into a vehicle do you
know is the home is that unknown
residence for him you know that sort of
thing I can't say positively that it is
his address but we do believe it could
be a family members and do you know who
would be if at all the warns that he was
wanted on would ever be released or
would that come from the u.s. marshals
that's something I really can't speak to
because those are not warrants that the
TVI has do that do the marshals wear at
body cameras that I'm not positive about
that you'd have to speak to the Marshal
Service but if so it would be part of
our investigation thanks guys
fire station we continue to call for
additional units officers did have the
dawn protective gear and we know that a
number of officers were injured and at
some point we did deploy chemical agent
the chemical agent appeared to be
effective in dispersing the crowd which
was our only goal the will continue to
maintain a heavy presence out there
tonight
we know that it's still an active scene
I do want to come in individuals that
did not decide to commit acts of
violence toward the police officers that
showed restraint I know that there are
many individuals in the crowd that try
to assist and keeping everyone calm so
I'm going to ask that the public allow
the Tennessee Bureau of Investigations
to do their job to conduct an
investigation and unfortunately what we
see when these acts occur a lot of
misinformation is put out I think there
are some individuals that try to agitate
a situation and it's unfortunate because
it hinders the truth from coming out the
MPD did make three arrests and I just
want to really again come in the Memphis
Police Department the Shelby County
Sheriff's Office the Tennessee Highway
Patrol niphas Fire Department and all of
our other first responders that came so
what I need now I need everyone to stay
calm if your home or your car was
vandalized or you were injured doing
these acts you know you need to call the
police if you witness a individual that
were throwing rocks or did something
that harmed a police officer are you
know committed an act of vandalism we
wants you to call the police or call
Crimestoppers and again I can't just
commend the the courage and the
restraint of
police officers but I am asking the
public to to allow the Tennessee Bureau
of Investigations to conduct their
investigation but my message tonight he
is is that we should all wait and and
make sure that we know exactly what
happened before we spread misinformation
or we jump to conclusions but you know
the Memphis Police Department we've been
very supportive of protests but we will
not allow any acts of violence will not
allow destruction of property will not
allow acts of vandalism to occur and you
know again I will continue to command
the officers for the enormous restraint
they show tonight I'll take a few
questions you know that are just
falsehoods that are out there right now
well obviously TV is going to conduct
the officer-involved shooting
investigation so I'm not going to
prematurely come in on that but you know
you so just as much as I did we know
that there's a lot out there and often
individuals do not have the facts and I
think that's dangerous well you know
we're still working on that number we
know at least 25 officers were injured
and most of them are minor injuries yeah
so that's a total count you know that
that could change as officers get home
and you know may discover that they had
a scrape or bruise but again the
officers did a enormous job tonight
showing restraint under very volatile
situation
he says mostly minor were there any
serious injuries there were a few
serious injuries but most of my minor
you know we know that you know the
officers we you know they're gonna make
a full recovery and hopefully get back
to work as soon as possible
why what were the charges that they were
arrested on yeah I'll let care and get
that back to you you know a you know
disorderly conduct inciting a riot and
they're there I think of those other
additional charge yeah we're still
talking to me you know in a situation
like this a lot happens we're still
working to get all the facts and you
know you always know that I don't like
to be premature and making statements
but out knowing the facts so again we're
asking for the public's calm we're
asking for the public's help and
identifying individuals responsible
because when these happen in a
neighborhood the neighborhood is
victimized
we know that we had some officers
injured tonight but the neighborhood is
victimized and you know we just want to
help return a sense of normalcy to that
neighborhood again allow TBI to conduct
their investigation and if you have
information please contact us I'll take
one more question about when officers
pull out the right here you know what
kind of situation needs to be presented
itself the one you saw tonight so that's
a great question so we had officers
coming from different locations I mean
you know officers originally that
responded to that scene right after the
shooting incident we're in their normal
uniform we've maintained the same
posture for the last few years where we
don't put on riot gear unless what we
think is necessary the people are
throwing rocks and bricks and and
objects that could harm a police officer
that's a tonight was a great example of
when it needs to be put on anything we
think there were reports of a few
civilians hurt and that's again that's
why we're asking for the public to
report yet they were injured and make
sure we can help investigate that
situation
they need medical treatment or they can
call number one or call the Memphis
Police Department we'll make sure we get
in transfer it to the fire department
thank you 25 approximately and we'll get
you the detailed numbers I mean we're
still kind of getting all this sorted
out thank you